so we should say we don't know anything
beyond what we just showed you the
pictures a lot of pictures that we just
put up we don't know how this happened
we of course don't know where it's going
nobody does but ben hall is clearly
right when he says this could be a
legitimate disaster for europe but of
course the invasion of ukraine already
is a legitimate disaster for europe and
the rest of the world europe just lost a
huge percentage of its energy supply
which is not a small thing we're all
being reminded of that
so this situation appears to become
more chaotic by the day possibly even
spinning out of control
and that we must be honest is shocking
to us
we've been taken by surprise by the
whole thing we're not the only ones who
were but we're willing to admit it the
only thing more embarrassing than being
wrong in your estimates is pretending
that you weren't
so why didn't we see this coming this
total loss of control
well because we assumed that if things
were dire
serious people would be involved in
fixing them but we looked up and we saw
kamala harris involved and that
reassured us harris had just come back
from europe where she'd been conducting
quote diplomacy with our allies and that
appeared to be proof this could not
really be a big deal the situation in
ukraine had been legitimately serious
if the future of europe and the world
hung in the balance as now so obviously
it does of course the biden
administration would not have sent
kamala harris to fix it because that's
not her job kamalaires's job is to trot
down to the blue room periodically to
greet delegations of tick-tock
influencers or to cut occasional psas
for the children's dental health
awareness month which is in february so
we assumed should be working on that
right now
but averting war with russia saving the
civilized world come on
that is absolutely not kamala harris's
job that was our assumption
but as noted we were wrong
why were we wrong well
we spend a lot of time watching kamala
harris you probably don't
unless you are a junior producer at
msnbc you're probably not that familiar
with kamala harris we should say by the
way
we didn't underestimate vladimir putin
we overestimated
joe biden
but we knew that once kamala harris was
involved it couldn't really be that
serious and we knew that because this is
what she's like
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border we've been to the
border you haven't been to the border
and i haven't been to europe
and i mean i don't thank you guys and my
pronouns are she her and hers she heard
her
she would look down at me and calmly
what do you want what do you want and i
looked back up and i said freedom
you're gonna literally see the craters
on the moon with your own eyes oh my
goodness with your own eyes i'm telling
you we must together work together
to see where we are
where we are headed but also see it as a
moment yes
to
together it is the perspective of of a
woman
who grew up a a black child in america
who was also a prosecutor who also has a
mother who arrived here at the age of 19
from india who also you know
likes hip-hop
[Laughter]
what do you want to know well i want to
this is just not a serious person not
surrounded by serious people and yet
we're in an extremely serious moment
that demands seriousness of course we
must together work together to see where
we are going together but also see
there's a moment together
if you've taken peyote you know what she
means otherwise you're probably baffled
once again it's time for us to do what
we've been doing and that time is every
day
it's like a gabron poem but the
illiterate version impossible to parse
when kamala harris speaks you get the
feeling you're either too dumb or too
smart to understand what she's saying
but then within a few sentences you
settle firmly on the ladder
what do european allies think of this
well of course they've come to the same
conclusion less than two weeks ago as
all this was brewing on the brink
the bide administration sent that person
kamala harris to represent the united
states at the munich security conference
in germany
and while she was there she assured the
world that she and joe biden had this
situation completely under control yes
putin would like to invade ukraine of
course he would but not on her watch not
while como di harris was on the same
continent this continent known as europe
no way
harris exuded what novelists call a
steely resolve imagine being first in
line for a shoe sale on black friday
kamal harris had that look she knew what
she wanted and she knew where to find it
and here's how she expressed that
resolve and yes this is a verbatim quote
from the munich security conference
quote
perhaps this is a moment as life does
present us with those moments that
challenge us to ask what is our reason
for being and i think we all know the
history of nato and its reason for being
the spirit behind this term we use the
transatlantic community the word
community meaning a collection not a
collection of individuals who see
themselves as a collection than as one
and that's where we are now
so if the vice president of the united
states
interrupts an adult security conference
to talk like that
you conclude that whatever crisis
they're talking about at the conference
couldn't be imminent they must have
plenty of time to fix it and that's why
they could afford to send kamala harris
in the first place because actually it's
not as big a deal as it seems
clear the white house must see european
heads of state is equivalent to
tick-tock influencers this is some kind
of photo op
that's what we concluded how could we
not conclude that
and then there was this clue
the day after kamala harris
said the words we just read
talked about her reason for being the
day after she said that she explicitly
encouraged ukraine to join nato quote i
appreciate and admire president
zielinski's desire to join nato she said
that at a press event
now we saw that we thought obviously the
biden people must have this under
control in some way we don't know about
they must have some secret back channel
to putin they must have been fully
assured that saying something so
unbelievably inflammatory is not going
to push putin to invade ukraine
we assume that i mean how could it be
otherwise it's the united states it's a
real country
the idea that ukraine might join nato
obviously caused this crisis in the
first place whatever you think of it
we know because we've watched for years
the more western leaders pushed the idea
of ukraine and nato the closer russians
came to invading ukraine
it's not a defense of that it's an
observation of it that's true so
obviously no sane person would say
something like that with russian troops
masked on the ukrainian border you'd
have to want an invasion of ukraine to
say something like that and at the time
we didn't think they did want that so we
got it completely wrong
and honestly we've continued to get it
wrong ever since we assume that once
kamal harris humiliated the united
states in munich and jeopardized its
core interests that maybe her boss joe
biden would realize maybe borders aren't
her thing maybe if you want to keep the
border between two countries from being
violated maybe you don't send kamala
harris
kamel harris believes borders are racist
or something so obviously it's pretty
hard for her to protect borders
so it's always a strange personnel
choice biden's been around a while you
think you know the key to good
management is matching the person with
the job not everybody's good at
everything
so if you're looking for someone to date
montel williams
well maybe she's
the person you would choose she could be
a solid choice that she's done it before
diddy montel williams
you know is something that's within her
range of experience is she good at it we
can't say she's but she's done it
but this new gig
de-escalating a world-ending conflict
with a nuclear-armed rogue state
no
no not when nuclear reactors are on fire
but they're doing it anyway
humiliating our country jeopardizing our
safety in the future of the world
kamala harris is now the point person on
ukraine in diplo speaks she's got the
ukraine portfolio
what's she doing with that portfolio
well starting at the beginning
explaining things the american public if
the world economy is going to collapse
and you no longer be able to afford meat
for dinner if europe's not going to have
power you should probably know why and
it has nothing to do they assure you
with the criminal negligence of people
like kamal harris and joe biden no
it's because a place called ukraine
listen
break it down to layman's terms for
people who don't understand what's going
on and how can this directly affect the
people of the united states so ukraine
is a country in europe it exists next to
another country called russia russia is
a bigger country russia is a powerful
country russia decided to invade a
smaller country called ukraine so
basically that's wrong
if you are patronizing people to that
degree in the middle of a crisis this
serious
you should not be in a position of
leadership translation i've never read a
book in my in my life i'm assuming you
haven't either let's talk ukraine is a
country in europe right okay following
you come on harris
can you imagine
watching this maybe you're starting to
understand what the whole point of this
administration is is the equity agenda
and under the terms of that agenda only
the least capable are allowed to assume
positions of authority in the united
states it's government by the dumbest
that's how pete but a judge a guy who
can barely drive his own car wound up in
charge of all of our roads
and so all these people got their jobs
it was intentional
now washington has worked this way to
some extent for a long time it's just
that under this president the principal
has reached its horrifying but logical
end point the last president hired
michael cohen to be his personal lawyer
but the difference is donald trump
didn't make michael cohen the attorney
general of the united states biden
absolutely would do that as long as
cohen was transgender and you know that
so it shouldn't surprise you though it
should horrify you and make you nervous
that according to the hill newspaper
kamala harris is going back to europe to
see how much worse she can make this
disaster she'll be heading to warsaw
poland in bucharest romania to quote
show solidarity with ukraine which means
to badly damage key american interests
in inventive new ways you haven't yet
imagined
that's what's going on a crisis that
gets more grave by the day whose
ramifications are clearly more serious
than anyone expected
overseen by people who have no wisdom or
foresight or restraint and fundamentally
don't have the interest of our country
at heart when they make their decisions
and kamala harris isn't the only problem
but she's the most glaring symbol of it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else